so i think we agree on some things i
think we disagree on some things but i
appreciate you listen being like i said
a citizen united states and contribute
how do i report this
um
okay so another installment of change my
mind where we air unedited conversations
on controversial topics and hear from
you in the comments section
today's topic is build the wall change
my mind
more so encompassing not just the wall
but immigration reform in general now
before we get to the interviews a couple
of things
first we didn't get many sit-down
interviews on this one
we got a lot of drive-by yellings two we
have people husky
and for the first time and change my
mind history we ran into a situation
that really shocked me was genuinely
disconcerting to the point where
we didn't know exactly what to do but to
start with this lady sat down to express
why she was against the wall trump or
the american people
is for building the wall yeah i'm not
against the illegal immigration
i'm i'm for that i want to come in
you're for illegal immigration
yeah you don't believe that you should
have to come here legally
they they need to come in here legally
but right now they aren't
but i don't want them to build a wall
okay so let me let me ask
i'm a little bit confused i want to make
sure that i understand this correctly
maybe i'm confused
no no i could be confused so you said
you support it so uh enforcing stricter
border policy for example
making sure that we know who's here
legally slamming down on work visas
deporting people who aren't here legally
uh don't
not allowing people to enter illegally
but you're against the physical wall
yes that wall is the one that that makes
me
mad makes me angry makes me want to cry
because
it's not i don't understand how that if
you're here in this country legally
you can still visit your family in
mexico and come back
no there's no guarantee for any of us
americans to go down there and visit our
you might even have family member down
there
you don't know i was raised in canada i
have family all the time in canada yeah
i've been to mexico if you're
if you're a legal citizen yeah you can
always while there's already starting
wars down there
uh um i'm talking too much now no
they're really like um
they're against the wall and if they
build it they're still going to get in
one way or another
you know what i'm saying right but you
already said that you're against that
yeah you said you're you you want some
kind of reform to stop people from
coming illegally
yeah so for what are you going to stop
them so why build it she's a
mexican-american immigrant
for context do you remember how vox told
you that sanctuary cities were necessary
because otherwise immigrants wouldn't
report crimes in their area
out of fear word gets out around the
immigrant community any time you
interact with local police it could mean
deportation eventually
immigrants will be afraid to call the
police even when they're the victims of
crime or the witnesses to it
it turns out it's not the cops these
people are most afraid of
i know a couple of i'm talking too much
now no no that's okay that's okay
don't say any names it's okay i know a
lot of people that are like
um are criminals
who aren't who haven't been deported
then they haven't been deported you
would support them being deported right
and there's a lot of them down there who
are doing like long-sleeve money for
that lending yeah
[Music]
so i think we would agree that we should
be able to deport them
right so you would be against like
sanctuary city laws that prevent
okay so i think we agree on some things
i think we disagree on some things but i
appreciate you listen being like you
said a citizen united states and
contribute
how do i report those
um how do you report them
yeah you report them to ice we spoke
with her more off air it breaks your
heart it really does keep in mind this
lady was a legal immigrant
subdued into fear by illegal immigrants
in her neighborhood
it's like we talk about all the time the
fake victim culture creates real
victims usually the ones following the
rules okay time for some unedited
interviews here
uh apparently this guy hosts a show
because he was really eager to step in
coming in hot
what's your name leroy lee nice to meet
you sir steven nice to meet you so i
guess it's called uh
build the wall change your mind why we
shouldn't build it no no why no i
support building the wall oh yes
but i'm telling you why i shouldn't
build it okay yeah so let me just sort
of assert my position first so maybe
because we might find some areas where
we disagree versus areas where we
disagree
um i believe in securing the border not
just the wall but securing the border
ensuring that we know who's entering the
country legally and illegally and uh
if there's anything where you think i'm
wrong you can more than welcome to
change my mind yeah
for from when it comes to like older
standards yeah like i could see where
you're saying build the wall
put today's standards in a migration we
could tax those people coming into the
country
and any money they make or any money
they spend will go into back into the
economy
so when it comes down to taxes and
people coming into the you know there's
a small
yeah sure there's like you know when it
comes down to it mexicans lions or
whatever you want to say
illegal immigrants in general coming to
the country bringing drugs
and i personally like i'm not mexican
i'm spanish i'm from
my family's been in new mexico since the
1550s around there
and i know a lot of mexicans in general
and a lot of them are hard working
people
and and a lot of them um a lot of them
put into the system so i don't yeah like
when it comes to crime there's like
maybe one like a small percentage that
brings you know brings drugs you know i
didn't bring that up i didn't say that
i'm not saying that the majority of
mexicans are bringing in drugs no i know
but i'm just going over the oh over what
trump and everybody else has said i
didn't say that either about
other people in general yeah and
actually he did say i know he did say
that he said
if you go back but trump said mexicans
are bringing
all the illegal drugs into the country
this and that like
hold on a second there are two different
things here because i want to make sure
it's i'm like a little update i'm a
little off because i've been
i've been caught up with the news for
like the package no i know what you're
referring to
and uh it was worded very poorly but
what you just said was that you know
a majority that most mexicans are
ringing and drugs committing crimes no
that's
that's certainly not donald trump's
position and i can't speak for everyone
else right who believes in securing the
borders
uh now that being said not a majority of
mexicans at all not a majority of
even illegal immigrants at all but they
do commit crimes
at a disproportionate level in
comparison to legal citizens yeah what
percentage though out of those
what percentage do you think say and
what percentage is that
do you think that commit crimes i want
to see your i want to get your input
but it's not my input so the statistics
would reflect that about about the
3.5 of the population united states are
undocumented immigrants
but they commit 37 percent of the
homicides of the murders
they commit up to 13 percent of the of
the uh the
violent crimes yeah 3.5
of the population illegal immigrants
commit 37 percent of the murders in this
country and
something depending on which state you
use 60 to 70 percent of drug trafficking
related charges
occur uh with people who are illegal
immigrants so not a majority of mexicans
but yes or immigrants not even a
majority of illegal immigrants
but they do commit crimes at
disproportionate levels so that's that's
an issue
yeah anybody today nowadays creates
crimes you know like
statistically sometimes specifically
statistically they're the ones bringing
the drugs but then statistically who are
the ones selling the drugs
yeah who are the ones selling the drugs
other american citizens adding to the
you know adding to the problem so we
can't just sit here
and point a finger i'm not i don't wanna
i don't want to get off on the topic
because you
brought to the drug thing so okay here's
my question for you you're off the
you don't support building a wall so um
i want to get your i want to understand
where you're coming from
do you support any type of uh border
enforcement any type of what should we
do about the illegal immigration problem
what should be done what would you do
just tax them get them get them uh get
them america get them legal citizens and
just tax them
put a yeah social uh social security id
number on them some ways somehow make
them pass the test
and just tax them make make money off of
them why throw them out of the country
when we could
make money off of them i'm not saying
make money off of them in a slave way or
bad way
and i know that's why i'm saying that
for my sophomore year i understand yeah
so but you know just tax them in general
make sure get them legal citizens if
there's
uh just make them pass the the courses
or whatever i don't know what the
i don't know what the criteria is today
for to make someone a citizen but
get them to be citizens make them
citizens and make them put into the
system
yeah because the migration and
immigration
is not going to stop it's only going to
get worse you know times just like
technology everything speeds up
so that's only going to increase along
with everything else so
so you believe in in making them legal
giving them a path to citizenship
exactly but you don't support a wall or
enforcing a board no or any type of
borders i think borders in general are
going to become a thing of the past
is what i've been talking to a lot of
people and it kind of i really see it
coming like i said with technology and
everything
people are going to just be able to
travel super fast
keep it you know super cheap and go
wherever they want and you know it might
not be now
but it will be in the next five you know
five to ten years let me ask you this
would we both agree because you said
give them the path to citizenship yes
but a lot of people who come into this
country don't want to pay taxes and
operate in the underground economy well
then they have to get but
we both agree that no matter what you do
even if you grant them that you're going
to have a certain amount of people
who are not going to pay taxes who will
stand under the radar do we agree on
that
yes okay so do you understand that what
you just described by not securing the
borders
you just talk about how we have this
we're never going to solve it because we
can't deport everybody right
exactly and you've just agreed i agree
that a lot of them are not going to pay
taxes and still stay undocumented that
if you don't secure the borders no i
didn't agree that no
not a lot of them there might be a
couple but i know a lot of them are
percentage
small percentage yes so if you have no
borders
if you have no uh securing our borders
if you have no way to monitor who's
coming in and out
you can see that what you just proposed
would create a veritable hell
real problem some kind of electronic id
tag of some sort you know
they have to have a passport of some
sort of documentation it's just not like
okay i'm going to walk you know they
have to how do you check that without a
border wall
i don't know like you know the amma if
they said this hasn't probably hasn't
i'm this is a free thought right now so
for me to execute this
i would have to get like a few uh
mastermind individuals to really sit
down and think this over
i cannot tell you bla bla a blatant
answer right now yeah i would have to
sit down a digital pass code exactly
some kind of digital passcode yeah so
they would have to go through a
checkpoint
exactly how do you get them to go
through a checkpoint if there's no wall
no it doesn't have to be a wall it could
be even like some kind of x-ray
x-ray scanner that you know as you walk
through it
you know your your number goes into a
database and
it registers when you when you got there
and when you left and maybe there might
be some other destinations that tag the
you know tag the id like you know in the
middle of the city to kind of get
a clue of where these you know people
that excuse me where these people are
in the in the area yes sir so an x-ray
border yeah an x-ray yeah next kind of
like
i don't know what like the proper
scientifical ray that's you but like an
x-ray
an x-ray gate that just reads your id
and says when you're there and
yeah and maybe like maybe before you
cross the border like give it like a
i don't know written explanation of why
you're why you're going to that place
you know
and but let it be more free-flowing you
know like yeah it's more free-flowing
so that's predicated on the idea that
people who are coming here illegally
right now
will obey you believe that they'll have
a written note as to why they're coming
to the country
and the x-ray border wall yeah that's
like that's just a general idea like you
know written whatever
that like i would have to talk to a
group of individual individuals and
think this over
computer engineers and i don't know i
one day plan on being the governor of
new mexico so i've been thinking a lot
about
i've been thinking about a lot of this
for the past three years yeah because
you know
new mexico has a lot of we're a
sanctuary city and we get a lot of these
people and we get a lot of
santa fe yeah santa fe new mexico and we
get a lot of immigrants and
a lot of people don't like them but at
the same time they may not like them but
i
really don't see it i really don't see
it slowing down anytime soon as much as
just like off topic but like when it
comes to the drug
the drug war we've been wasting
thousands millions trillions of dollars
since the 70s and have we seen any have
we seen any positive no so like we're
just going against the grain on this one
and particularly without any kind of a
border right it makes the drug war
really hard
uh either way you know without drugs
being brought in by
immigrants is a small percentage
compared to pharmaceuticals
that already been on the news and been
dumping billions and billions of opiates
into and every other drug you know it's
i consider
an immigrants a small percentage of the
real the real boss hogs the real drug
dealers that are out there
doing it illegally just because it's fd
jack appreciate it
i don't know that's okay i know you said
well do me a favor here because this is
obviously about changing my mind
i don't i don't agree with you okay but
i respect you yes thank you sir so when
you do sit down and i know you kind of
had this idea he said it's going to take
a while for you to formulate it
uh formulate the the idea yes when you
do with the i don't mention the x-ray
sort of border
and tagging uh you know then uh then let
us know email us through the website and
maybe we can have you on and talk about
it because i don't want you i don't want
you to be on the spot if you're like
well i need some time
yes sir yes sir thank you man my name is
leroy trio and i'm here with go green
global thank you everybody thank you
leroy
appreciate it
hey there youtube viewer if you like
this video watch one of my other videos
oh
it's playing in one of those boxes uh
i'd say subscribe or hit the
notification bell but i don't really
know what that means in today's day and
age on youtube but if you join it louder
with crowder.com club you won't only see
clips
you'll get to watch the full daily
one-hour show every single day and
support our content making sure that we
can still get clips up here on youtube
for the free loaders who can't afford it
and or are just
cheap pricks